HARRIS?
>> MELISSA: MIKE TOBIN, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR CUOMO IS
CRITICIZING LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS WHO REFUSE TO ENFORCE
THE STATE’S LATEST COVID-19
RESTRICTIONS, INCLUDING THE
10-PERSON CAP ON PRIVATE
GATHERINGS AHEAD OF
THANKSGIVING.
WATCH THIS.
>> I DON’T BELIEVE IN THAT LAW,
AND THEREFORE I WON’T ENFORCE
IT, THAT IS FRANKLY FRIGHTENING
TO ME, AS AN INDIVIDUAL,
FRIGHTENING TO DEMOCRACY.
IT’S ARROGANT, AND IT VIOLATES
THE CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY.
>> HARRIS: MY NEXT GUEST SAYS
GUESS WHAT?
HE’S ACTUALLY NOT GOING TO
ENFORCE THE GOVERNOR’S LET’S ON
SOCIAL GATHERINGS.
FULLERTON COUNTY SHERIFF RICHARD
JOINS ME.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH ME.
FIRST OF ALL WHAT GOES THROUGH
YOUR MIND WHEN YOU HEAR THE
GOVERNOR SAY WHAT HE JUST SAID,
THAT YOU DON’T HAVE THE RIGHT TO
NOT, JUST NOT FOLLOW THE
RESTRICTIONS?
>> IT DISTURBS ME BECAUSE I
DON’T THINK HE UNDERSTANDS THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN A LAW, WHICH
WE LEARNED WHEN WE WERE YOUNG,
THAT A LEGISLATURE PASSES A BILL
AND IT GOES TO THE GOVERNOR OR
PRESIDENT, AND THEY SIGN IT, OR
VETO IT, AND AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
LEGISLATURE OF NEW YORK
ADVOCATED THE RULE BY GIVING
FULL AUTHORITY TO THE GOVERNOR.
THESE ARE EXECUTIVE ORDERS.
THAT’S WHY HE CAN ISSUE AN ORDER
TO A BAR, RESTAURANT OR GYM
BECAUSE THEY ALL HAVE LICENSES
UNDER THE STATE LIQUOR AUTHORITY
OR HEALTH DEPARTMENT SO
THEREFORE HE HAS CONTROL UNDER
THE AUTHORITY OF HIS
DEPARTMENTS, AND THEY CAN LIMIT
HOURS.
THEY CAN LIMIT MASKS, DISTANCING
AND SEATS IN A RESTAURANT AND
FIND THEM BUT AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER, ENTERING A HOME, EVERYONE
GETS THE SENSE WITHOUT EVEN
BEING ABLE TO CITE THE LAW THAT
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH THAT.
INTERESTING, YOUR LEAD-IN IN
OREGON IT WAS SIX PEOPLE IN YOUR
HOME.
NEW YORK IS 10.
SO DOES THAT MEAN THAT THE COVID
IS MORE DANGEROUS IN OREGON AND
LESS DANGEROUS IN NEW YORK?
IT MEANS YOU’RE PICKING
ARBITRARY NUMBERS SO THAT’S ONE
REASON IT WOULD NOT SURVIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL MUSTARD.
AS A FORMER SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE
AND DISTRICT ATTORNEY IT’S
INCUMBENTS ON THE GOVERNOR AND
MYSELF TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION AND I’LL STAND BY
THE CONSTITUTION EVERY DAY OVER
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER.
>> HARRIS: STEUBEN COUNTY
SHERIFF, ANOTHER AREA OF NEW
YORK, JAMES -- SAID IN A
STATEMENT OFFICERS WILL NOT BE
PEEKING IN YOUR WINDOW OR
ATTEMPTING TO ENTER YOUR
PROPERTY TO COUNT THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AT YOUR TABLE ON
THANKSGIVING.
YOU MENTIONED THOSE NUMBERS.
I BRING UP THAT.
GOVERNOR CUOMO SAYS HE’S NOT
INTERESTING ANYBODY TO DO THAT
BUT SAID IF THEY RECEIVED
COMPLAINTS OR HAPPEN UPON LARGE
GROUPS INSIDE FOR THE HOLIDAYS,
THEY SHOULD BREAK UP THE PARTY.
HOW DO YOU HAPPEN UPON MY LIVING
ROOM?
THAT’S ON THE BACKSIDE OF MY
HOUSE?
>> GOOD QUESTION.
GOOD QUESTION.
ONE OF THE SUGGESTIONS WAS, IF
THERE ARE 10 CARS AND A NEIGHBOR
COMPLAINS WE STILL NEED A SEARCH
WARRANT.
YOUR CONSENT.
WE CAN’T JUST GO INTO YOUR HOME,
AND THE PROBLEM IS IT WAS ILL
PHRASED BECAUSE IT GAVE PEOPLE
THE IMPRESSION THAT THE GOVERNOR
WAS TELLING THEM, THAT THERE IS
SOME SANCTION INVOLVED.
PEOPLE RESPOND BETTER WHEN THEY
ARE ASKED TO COMPLY IN.
OUR STATE, THE NUMBERS ARE VERY
LOW.
1.3% COUNTY AND PEOPLE HAVE TO
REMEMBER THAT OUR GOAL IS TO
KEEP PEOPLE ALIVE AND REDUCE
THIS BUT IT’S GOT TO BE DONE IN
A CONSTITUTIONAL MANNER AND WHAT
WE KNOW IS 99% PLUS OF PEOPLE
WHO CONTRACT IT GET OVER IT IN A
FEW WEEKS.
UNFORTUNATELY, THOSE AT
HIGH-RISK DIE, AND DR. FAUCI HAS
BEEN TELLING US FOR EIGHT
MONTHS, THE NUMBERS ARE GOING TO
RISE IN THE FALL, THE NUMBERS
ARE GOING TO RISE AND GET BAD.
SO SOMEBODY SAID TO ME, IF
PEOPLE GET COVID IN YOUR COUNTY,
YOU HAVE BLOOD ON YOUR HANDS.
IT’S UP TO THE INDIVIDUAL TO
DECIDE, BY NOW THEY ALL KNOW
WHAT THE PRECAUTIONS AND ADVICE
IS, STAY AWAY, MASK, AND I THINK
PEOPLE ARE SMART ENOUGH NOT TO
PUT THE ELDERLY AND PEOPLE AT
RISK IN THAT ENVIRONMENT AND
MOST PEOPLE WHO SUPPORT ME,
SUPPORT THE CONSTITUTION BUT
THEY ALSO SAY THEY ARE CHANGING
THEIR THANKSGIVING THIS YEAR.
THEY ARE LIMITING IT TO JUST
FAMILY.
AND THEY JUST PASS OVER IT SO
PEOPLE ARE DOING THAT WITHOUT AN
ORDER TO DO SO.
>> HARRIS: WELL, NOT ONLY ARE
THEY HEARING WHAT YOU’RE SAYING
BUT THEY KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT AND YOUR
BACKGROUND AS A FORMER JUDGE
MAKE THE CASE.
SHERIFF, FULTON COUNTY, NEW
YORK, THANK YOU, GREAT TO SEE
YOU TODAY.
>> THANK YOU, HAVE A NICE
WEEKEND AND A LIMITED TO 10
THANKSGIVING DAY.
>> HARRIS: I’M GOING TO ADHERE
TO PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY AND
DO WHAT YOU SAY.
>> DON’T TELL ME HOW MANY YOU
HAVE OR WE’LL HAVE TO SENDS A